Your goal is to make a simple model to manipulate in future units. You'll
create a basic drinking bird model, very basic. At this point he won't even
have a beak. We'll get to that in a later unit. The drinking bird is a little
toy that drinks from a cup. Google it. The objects you'll make are the legs,
body, head and jaunty hat. Here's the blueprint showing front and side views.
Well, it's more of a back-of-the-napkin drawing, but sometimes that's all you
get from a client. Me, my favorite client comment I heard that one designer
received was, could you make that sphere rounder? The three objects you'll use
are the cube, well, box, sphere, and cylinder. Here are the typical calls for
creating these three objects. For the cube, the numbers passed ten are the
width, height, depth of the box. The sphere needs just a radius to describe
it's geometry. The additional two numbers specify how much tessellation happens
along the equator and from pole to pole, respectively. You might try changing
these tessellation numbers to see the effect on the body, but please use these
numbers, 32 and 16, when you submit your answer. The cylinder gives an upper
and lower radius, followed by a height, and by the amount of tessellation along
its equator. Again, please use the number 32. See the additional course
materials for documentation for these various methods. There are three
functions you'll be working on. The function, CreateSupport, will make the
drinking bird's support frame, base, legs and feet. To get you started, I've
laid down a base that the legs connect to, along with the left leg. You'll have
to add the right leg and feet. The function, CreateBody, will create the bird's
body and spine. The function, CreateHead, will make the head and hat. You have
to create the objects in the correct location and add them to the scene. When
you've done that, you'll see the model of the drinking bird, just like it's
shown here.